into the year
particularly moving forward to
um
apologies are received from Council
letterkers
um
too much
yes
GM traffic look healthy
I'm Caroline Segal I'm a housing
strategy growth manager at the council
hello Sarah chief executive at Trafford
Council and place basically in the
Health and Care integration for traffic
I'm sure
uh Public Health consultant and he
probably has team in the council
Angel C dot manager for today's live
traffic
[Music]
hi I'm Liz Carlton from greatest mental
health
director for our place at Catholic
Council
Harry cullah the governance officer
English
[Music]
volunteer community
organization
um
again
[Music]
exploring everybody Liz Murphy the
relatively newly appointed independent
chair and scrutinator of the Trafford
strategic safeguard
hi everyone
um
so if we can just go through the agenda
and minutes from the last board are
there any
issues with the minutes
can we agreed them
thank you and the first oh a couple of
questions for the public so the next
item is an item five appointment advice
chair so we've had
um
some interest in the post and I'd like
to welcome Garrett as the advice
I I honestly I
we can sort it out the screen as well
and if we can then move on to item sixes
over to you Caroline and our housing
strategy
and everyone tonight
it's probably worth saying that because
we're being broadcast
um it won't work for broadcast
effectively if people are watching if
it's not on the night I'm afraid so it's
probably a message for everybody so
thank you okay so I'll use the mic
hopefully
uh so yeah I'm Caroline sigal housing
strategy and growth manager and just
here to give you an update on the
housing strategy so what we did
previously and the consultation that's
recently took place for the development
of the new strategy and the time frame
for developing that new strategy
so the council is in the process of
developing a new strategy that will run
for a period of five years from 2024
next year to 2029. we began consultation
in the middle of May with a survey for
residents and we held some listening
sessions with key stakeholders residents
Council staff during June responses from
the survey and the listening sessions
are being used to shape and drafting of
the new strategy
foreign
so the last housing strategy was
launched in June 2018 and ran until it's
running until the end of this year and
the delivery of that strategy is being
led by our strategic Housing Partnership
and each year we um undertook an annual
review of the strategy that determined
what we've achieved what was underway
and what we still had left to do those
annual statements are all published on
the website
these were the seven strategic
priorities that we had in the 2018-23
strategy the intention is to reduce uh
for the next strategy it was quite an
undertaken with these seven strategic
priorities but that was what we had
previously
and just to give you some achievements
what we've achieved over the past five
years and some Achievers particularly
from last year in terms of new build we
developed 977 new build residential
units which were completed in 2122 which
is an increase of 323 from the previous
year
255 new build affordable units completed
last year which was an increase of 338
percent
we've launched the Trafford affordable
housing fund which basically combines
any monies we see from Developers for
off-site affordable housing into a fund
that allows housing associations to bid
for that money and and provide social
accommodation in the borough
we've um with that funding for the
church affordable housing fund um Ellen
Kuhn formerly Trafford Housing Trust
develops 3 one and two bedroom
apartments in timperley and we are on
site currently with Linda courts in sale
which is a long-term empty property in
sale
um lnq formally tht and we're bringing
forward 10 social rented units again
funded through that that fund
we developed a number of joint ventures
and with bruntwood in the Civic course
and Shop stretch them all and in
Tamworth in Old Trafford with lnq we've
got some new student accommodation
that's been developed just on the corner
over there at Academy Apartments
formerly Warwick house opposite to the
UA 92.
we understood the housing need and
demand assessment once the strategy was
launched in 2018 and the 2023 update is
underway
um the older person's housing strategy
was launched in 2020 it also developed
an empty home strategy and a supported
housing strategy and a homelessness
strategy and just some key statistics in
terms of homelessness last year we
prevented just under 350 housing
households from becoming homeless which
was an increase of 12 on the previous
year
the Amazons to stay in bed and breakfast
has been reduced from 20 days to 14 and
we've rehoused 336 from the council's
register
so in terms of the development of the
strategy this is an initial time frame
in terms of um what we're looking for
looking to in terms of development of
that strategy so as I said the initial
consultation started in the middle of
May and it ended in at the end of June
we had some listening sessions
throughout June we're in the process of
drafting the document and following that
consultation and hoping to have a first
initial draft in November or the final
version in sort of December and January
to go out to some public consultation in
February March any final amendments will
be made around April and May and and the
plan is to launch the strategy following
exec approval in June July
in terms of the consultation this is
just some key findings from that survey
that we launched on the 15th of May 976
responses from residents and these are
some of the key areas that the residents
of Trafford felt were important so we
had 25 of the residents experience sort
of disrepair 18 in the private relative
sector 26 in social housing and 56
homeowners it was surprising to see the
percentage of social rented uh in that
so it is of course was concern in terms
of disrepower
the most common experience you suppose
around structural defects and dampen
mold which we mentioned at the previous
meeting and uh scrutiny committee are
looking at Danbury mold as it as an
issue in this sector
32 are considering moving um to a
different property
um 88 on to remaining Trafford
40 intend to move within the next 18
months
and 23 within 6 to 12 months and 19
within the next six months and to 18
within 12 to 18 months
the most common reason for wanting to
move is to become a homeowner or to live
in a larger property
and 77 of those considering a movement
would prefer to be a homeowner and then
rent or
um yeah from a private or social
landlord
72 believe the main housing issue in
Trafford is affordability which we all
know Trafford is the most expensive
Borough in Greater Manchester and we
have a huge affordability issue so
that's not surprising to hear from
residents
and the lack of social housing and
Independence I can't even say that word
inadequate supply of available housing
and the poor infrastructure are the
three most commonly identified issues
in terms of demographics from some of
the respondents this slide here just
shows you who who responded
um majority uh well 61 were female
um
it was quite a big it was quite a split
in terms of age genographic but majority
of being 55 and over majority of being
white British
um and this this slide here just talks
about also the um main sources of income
and
um that most people had an income
between uh household income between 20
000 and 40 000.
and this is some of the the housing
circumstances of the respondents
currently so 25 of the respondents as
I've mentioned our experience and an
issue with disrepairing their home 61 of
the respondents experiencing this repair
around structural defects 48 around
Danville 27 around electrical defects 32
of respondents are considered moving an
eight percent one to remain in Trafford
just a summary based of what we said
previously in those points let's give
you an idea of what the strategy is
going to look like it's going to have a
lot more pictorial
um information like these slides in the
document rather than lots and lots of
writing
and again the main housing issue we
talked about affordability is the
highest 72 microsocial housing and
supply of housing following
infrastructure so
um was came up quite high in terms of
Roads GPS and education schools
um was a woman with the new Estates now
being developed
so that graph energy shows and what
people thought the main housing issues
were
and this slides around what's where the
respondents felt we should be looking at
in terms of priorities
so building more affordable homes on
social housing was up there at the top
infrastructure followed that and
Brownfield first approach which is what
the council and looks to do anyway
bringing empty homes back into use
protecting the green belts addressing
issues in the private emergency sector
Energy Efficiency and looking at
reviewing our allocations policy
the listening sessions just asked a
series of questions which at the end of
this presentation I'm going to ask you
to get involved in those questions using
slido but this is just
a word cloud based on some of the key
points that people said in that and
those listening sessions and as you can
see affordabilities is key in the cost
of living increasing housing Supply
social housing affordable housing are
ones that popped out and quite a lot
so in terms of the strategy for twin
School 29 we've looked at what people
said and we've started to draft some
priorities
so the first one is about increasing
that supply of housing but looking to
build truly affordable homes so when we
refer to truly affordable homes it's
goals that are linked to local income
levels affordable housing tends to be
affordable events tends to be around 80
of Market rent and in some cases isn't
affordable to to the residents of
Trafford so working with our Housing
Association partners and our development
team to see if we can develop truly
affordable homes that are linked to
local income levels
so this section of the strategy will
include information about what we've got
currently in terms of Housing and the
tenure
um what we've got in the pipeline in
terms of develop delivery of Housing and
affordable housing and looking at truly
affordable homes as a topic and and
doing some analysis on local incomes and
um so we can determine what that term
truly affordable means
the next priority we're looking at is
around is showing that traffic residents
can access and sustain their homes so
this is around ensuring that um homeless
nurses prevented that there is that
tenancy sustainment so in this section
we'll be looking at how people can
Access housing the Trafford whole Choice
system and the allocations policy which
is a policy that determines how we
allocate homes uh
um fairly homeless prevention as it
touched on and tenancy support
the next sections around ham in showing
homes meet current and future needs so
this will be around the results of our
housing aid assessment that's currently
ongoing sustainability the zero carbon
agenda retrofit fuel poverty property
conditions which has come out very
strongly and some of the comments we've
received in terms of damper mode so in
that section that's that's what we'll be
looking at there and the final
um priority is around neighbors of
choice initial inequalities and places
want to live so it's around Place making
our new design code and design guide the
places for everyone
um
infrastructure and looking at Health
inequalities which is um obviously this
board's main aim
so I've got some questions for you and
it's going to be using a slider some of
us these are the questions and I just
bring up the other presentation on slido
so that you can then log in and look to
help answering these questions hopefully
this will work
so on the screen in a moment will be the
code or if you are already logged into
slido
um you just um enter that hashtag there
once you're all ready let me know
and these questions that we ask
um are the ones that we we did in the
listening sessions so
scanning that code she'll take you to
the website and allow you to just log in
hopefully
okay
technology Whirlwind let me know if you
have any problems
[Music]
everyone okay everyone managed to get in
okay no worries
I'm taking a selfie
foreign
the questions which is great so it's
asking me the health and well-being
board what do you think the key housing
issues are in Trafford
affordability again is is coming up
affordability and availability lack of
supported accommodation
so lots of
um similarities to what residents have
said and what what other people's uh or
the stakeholders mentioned in the
listening sessions as well
yeah
is everyone a chance to answer
so 11 have mentioned some type of
affordable affordability being an issue
and lack of stock lack of land
and thank you for that
move on to the next question
is what do you think is meant by truly
affordable housing and what can we do to
increase affordable housing in traffic
so I mentioned before what we believe
the definition of truly affordable
housing is you've got another
definition if you really want to share
and also and what you how you feel we
can increase
I don't know what's just happened there
sorry about that
people are busy typing away
let's bring it back up again
the things needs to be coming through so
I think my other technical problem
okay here we go
so yeah definitely need to look at
affordable housing and how it links to
income levels
um local housing allowance rates are an
issue I think government nationalities
to review those those rates
thank you
[Music]
a third of the salary is is you know 30
of your salary is what should be being
spent on on the rent or mortgage that's
not happening
and lots of people are spending up to 70
at the moment
yeah and I think as we used to say is
around that insufficient amount of homes
that are being delivered nationally we
are in a housing crisis so demand for
housing particularly in traffic which is
a popular area is pushing rents and
house prices up through the roof so
hopefully everyone's answered that when
we go to the next question
reached around the private rented sector
and what we feel the issues are in that
sector
cost definitely
and we find that huge issue in traffic
particularly to looking to re-house
those uh the homeless
and landlords in traffic can charge in
excess of you know thousands of pounds a
month and they're not in line with the
local housing allowance
rates the government set that determines
what benefits people get for the housing
costs
[Music]
you think there needs to be some
regulation on rents how we do that it is
going to be a difficult one and I think
we're going to lose a number of
landlords as well within the next 12 to
18 months with the new legislation
that's coming in APC of 18c and above
some properties are not able to be
improved to that level so and they're
going to look at selling them and not
benefiting them out anymore
so that will decrease the number of
properties we have available and with
mortgage interest rates
um I'm sure I'm also considering whether
it's actually worth renting their
properties again selling selling them
so we've watched this space with that
really yeah quality and availability and
we do a very low amount of private
rental properties in traffic compared to
other areas in in Greater Manchester
foreign
which is around sustainability zero
carbon and how we address those in you
and existing homes
[Music]
you're right to your visit
I think in some cases some of the
properties that are are in Trafford the
older Terrace type offices
in some cases not even possible to
retrofit
um
I'm gonna have a struggle with it with
with existing accommodation I think with
new build we can ensure that they meet
the uh let's say a real carbon um
targets with existing stuff we may
struggle to uh to do that
it's definitely needs to be more support
from government about retributing the
risk funding available book is
definitely not enough
and housing associations have been given
um bigger targets than developers so we
might find that some of the stock that
they have currently if they are unable
to retrofit or make those improvements
that they're going to end up selling
selling that stock off which you then
will reduce the amount of social events
and accommodation we have which again is
a worry
so move on to the next question
which is around homelessness
so what can we do to end homelessness
I've worked in housing for nearly 20
years and there's no chance of ever
ending homelessness unfortunately and I
think it's getting worse particularly
with the cost of living crisis that
we're all currently experiencing
um Trafford at the moment as had on
precedence a number of people in bed and
breakfast usually it was at a minimum of
under 10 people at one point last month
we had around 50 households bed and
breakfast
um so yeah we can just see that that's
uh ending homelessness is a challenge
but if anyone's got any great ideas and
how we can and homelessness then please
write them in the slides here
foreign
ultimately if it's down to finance and
affordability and you can get as much
support as you as you can but
um that's where the issue potentially
would result in you becoming homeless
[Music]
housing first is a great approach
um in going to Manchester we've had some
real successes with housing first so
those that don't know about it it's
about ultimately looking for those most
chaotic and homeless individuals have
been around the homeless cycle for a
number of years potentially sleeping
rough
and
providing them with a house initially
and then making sure that their support
comes in afterwards in most cases
you have to be a certain type of person
to get a tendency in the within Housing
Association minimal rental careers
support plans in place and that's not
usually right for these these
individuals so housing first has worked
and and yet increasing those approaches
will be good
yeah I'm in terms of obviously because
traffic does have low numbers of rough
sleepers compared to other areas of
Greater Manchester I think we've got two
entrance to a sleepers but hosts
continually engage with
um
but who are who don't want that support
and want to continue to live the way
that they do and what we do have is a
lot of sofa surface and a lot of
households who are becoming homeless for
various reasons and we have a duty team
to come to place and in some cases has
to be in bed and breakfast because we
don't have that availability of housing
yeah a mental health assistance you see
support I think is is a huge issue I
think we need more definitely to help
sustain those those tenances
and the final questions around
um creating labels of choice and
addressing inequalities and what do you
think we should should do
to to create those neighborhoods of
choice and address those inequalities
foreign
model and yeah put a good idea I know
that the previous meeting Tommy
mentioned about those uh neighborhood
hops
um some link making sure housing is
LinkedIn in with that and that each
enabled has a different approach
depending on the needs of those
communities
[Music]
resources to those in greatest need more
affordable housing
neighbor neighborhood models been
mentioned again
how to travel or transport boots yeah I
think the key to creating those
neighborhoods
I mean traffic we've got some new
neighborhoods that are being created in
Trafford Waters the Trafford Center
there's a whole new area a whole new
neighborhood being created there so it's
making sure that it's not just around
the housing and the support the
education the health offer that we can
offer as well as the roles in in those
and the links to transport in those
areas as well as also Carrington a huge
opportunity in Carrington to create
again new neighborhoods so how can we
create those neighborhoods of choice and
make sure that those inequalities are
addressed
green spaces and cleaner
all great ideas
so thank you that's the end of the
questions and what you have said will
feed into the drafting of the strategy
we will include your comments in along
with what we've included within the um
listening sessions
so if there's any further questions
to answer them
isn't going to surprise you at all but
just to say we've obviously had a number
of comments around recent years of
people with mental health issues and
also we all know the importance of
housing for well-being and so really
welcome a conversation outside of this
meeting about how we can work at this
really important planning State how we
can incorporate the needs of people who
are perhaps not able to access
accumulation in the way we would want
yeah definitely and full of engine
eating outside and I'll invite my
colleague Rob Miller who is a service
manager post to get involved in those
conversations as well that'd be great
thank you very much
thank you
I keep going but it's really interested
and I did like an interact with it at
the end managed to get on and do it yeah
and the things and stuff that's in there
that have been you know the companies
are doing around
you know the building of social mental
properties and obviously reduction in
people and our residences bed and
breakfast doesn't really important
things because thanks for all Hardware
that you do with royalty
right and we can move on then to item
seven and it's low quality performance
Insurance framework and of course
or something
how's it impressed with that it's a
normal paper
totally people have a chance to have a
look at through the table because it's
starting to tease out sort of how this
will work so it's just a bit of a recap
we've talked previously about the
development of the operator model at the
GM level for the new integrated care
system architecture and by operating
model I mean pretty simply you know
who's with what where so falling out of
that Clarity that we're starting to get
of what we'll be doing in the locality
we're now working on we're trying to
develop further
Performance Management framework so on
the back of the delegation to locality
and understanding against what is going
to GM what is the locality
of how we will provide that Assurance
around some of those key and
a strategic and operational deliverable
so so in the table hopefully it's fairly
self-explanity what we've tried to do
and this is a GM documentary that we've
tailored here to to show how that might
work in Trafford is to work through some
of the natural requirements the GM
requirements and then start to talk
about what we do in the locality and how
we'll manage those so there's a couple
of examples from the table firstly
what's described as the NHS oversight
framework is a national framework
produced each year by the nhse at
Manchester England which
um has a broad range of metrics and
deliverables so what we're clear on now
is which of those are going to be
monitored in the locality which would be
done at a GM level you know an ICB level
to what proposing is where we will
manage that in traffic so that will be
through
currently through the Health and Social
care
Steering group or then through the
locality board who should be operating
for more than a year now but that might
change and we develop into a financial
performance group to underpin that but
that's what we're suggesting now then
another one around the better care fund
is also a national program but our
proposal will be as you'd expect that
that will be escalated through the
health and well-being board
so one of the coupons we wanted to make
in this
kind of links very much to the
conversation that we had last time I
think in July around the table when the
time started with the piece of work
we've been doing but going through the
GM strategy but also the five year
forward plan to to make sure that we've
got all of those areas covered
recognizing uh that you know there will
be inevitably some gaps against that so
so this piece of work it links really
closely to that starting to put a bit
more flesh on the bones so what we will
be doing in the locality in the first
place and there's where and how we will
do that
make just another comment for provider
colleagues and get really conscious
of the fact that we need to strike a
balance between
truly robust Arrangements in the
locality so we can excited delegation
but also not have duplication for public
colleagues and making life more
complicated because it's already a very
complicated system in terms of assurance
and regulation so so working with
Partners across GM but more importantly
now through through the governments
we've set up in Trafford to really get
something in the works for us you know
so we really have a good whole of this
and provide Assurance against and the
key things that we want to understand
the Trafford so towards the end of the
paper we've just put some some bullet
points in terms of some of the key
things that we'd like a bit more
feedback and we should have probably
start
to the conversations I'm going to have
with colleagues moving forward well
that's probably Enough by way of
instruction in terms of the progress
we've made hopefully it shows that there
is some progress in terms of that
understands
get quite a bit of work to do on the
detail thank you
thank you tariff and I think everybody
can see the key consideration into the
acts and four so if anybody's got any
thoughts ideas questions that they want
to do so that we can actually take some
feedback so I think we were hoping last
time that we would have a bit more
debate around those topics so
everybody has to be on some questions
got it
okay
[Music]
um
so yeah I suppose I really welcome
obviously the framework together but I
suppose it's the channel sports has
evolved to link up to the so what
questions
and because all this stuff aren't valid
look
yeah
this is about so
so what so so there will be something
that in the locality that we have to
provide Assurance against some of the
national and the GM metrics as we said
but for us it is about what's important
to Trafford so it is and it probably
won't be right in the first few months
and it will develop over the next year
or so but really understanding what the
key priorities for traffic on I think we
know that because we've done lots of
working authorities but making sure that
we spend most of our time talking about
that and how we're doing against those
rather than some of the more National
ones so so I totally agree and that's it
for us to shape I think
Etc but included my question really is
about in even the conversations that
have taken place to date what would you
say the parity of focus is between
children and adults in terms of the
performance framework
it's a really good question so so I
would suspect that it's not a fair split
between children and adults and so we've
made a real a real conscious effort in
the last six months
to increase explosion on the insurance
around children's services so for
example the Children's Commission board
now feeds directly into the locality
board and after the conscious decision
to make it really prominent and we've
had several really quite hard hitting
reports going through locality boards so
I think we're getting there but in terms
of the framework that needs to be
confidentially
of absolute imperative and some of the
some of the areas need to be not
children's or adults they get a bit
frustrated I don't know everyone
probably does it needs to be about that
service coming with adults and children
so so Jill let me Reagan as you know it
was really vocal in sort of promoting
this and I think we're all getting a bit
more familiar with that now so so then
you're probably not provide where we
wanted to be now but I think we are
making countries and efforts to make
sure it is
around
[Music]
Amy brilliant thanks gavis so there's a
couple of things for me I think well
this is really good that this is finally
coming because we need to see it I think
there's a piece for me as you do it
there's some potential duplication some
of the metrics I think that the best
thing is as we start to populate it and
making sure we're not seeing the same
thing twice I'm really welcome the fact
that we recognize that kind of providers
and organizations have their own
performance systems that we need to sort
of I think a key thing for us to work
together on as we mobilize this is
get into conversations where one person
has one set of data that's done as one
thing and supercomplete with another key
here is
Nathan said how is that helping us
understand and drive in our priorities
but I know
um
perspective we really want to work with
you on some of this notwithstanding as
final times the challenges with data and
Community Services especially in
Community Health Services and current
talk to some of the other areas but you
just need to make sure that we're
putting the right data in the right
system so that we can see the right
performance
foreign
and that's absolutely right because
there might be some
consequences of that for them that will
have a real impact on what we're trying
to do with their locality then we'll
need to come through here on locality
but not duplicating the Assurance but
having them understand the only impact
on the traffic population isn't it and I
think it's going to take some time to
get that rhythm of how we do it so I'd
really like to get something get started
thank you um
I think the uh in noting of all the um
the other comments I think probably one
of the
um really helpful things that we are
about to embark on is a refresh of our
locality plan which we've discussed at
the I guess that's what you were going
to say as well which we've discussed at
the at the locality board
um but in that discussion talked about
how that locality plan could be our plan
for Trafford so that what we have is a
single plan and don't have a separate
health and well-being strategy and so
that we knit those things together and
for me that is so what that isn't it
that helps us bring together in one
place what our priorities are and that
that then steers us right in the you
know clearly in the direction of what do
we need to measure in order to determine
whether we need you know whether we're
making the progress that we need to make
so that piece of work is something that
we
um we should be bringing here I assume
at the next meeting actually it will be
timely to do that so that we can keep
that piece of work off and the course of
the next six months or so move ourselves
to a place where we've got an
overarching
um plan that helps us bring together
those priorities make sure that we've
got that right balance as well but also
recognizing that there is a lot going on
in our system isn't that and that
Simplicity in that one place would just
be really helpful
thank you
absolutely so much on the button it much
hurt more eloquent than I would have got
um thank you and so probably just
building on that and slightly taking a
look back so we have a giant hold back
that Gary saluded to which has Marietta
um priorities over the next five years
some of which we can do year one and
some of which will be will be today's
over the five-year giant pilot fund time
frame and we'll need to think about I
suppose the role of the health and
wellbeer board and the act as possible
within this group compared to other
groups and forums that we have in
Trafford so what will it be more plots
to achieve
um within its membership and what are
the low power support and want to and
need to do Midlands substitute juices
and what's the bits in the middle that
will need both for them to work together
and and that making sure it meets its
way into the ultimate product that will
be the local health insurance framework
I think is really important it's
probably it's more of a placehold of
this whilst we belong to it very sharply
in terms of the inequality
but if the health and well-being workers
think about how it
um has maybe a critical friend role to
think about how inequalities are all of
the other work that's happening in the
provide a collaborative board in the
locality board that keeps us coming back
to is what we are doing is it making a
difference
are we having traffic might be an
interesting way of positioning the role
of this problem in a good performance so
we can do that through the process that
salvages outline in terms of
professional locality plan and bring you
into health and well health and
well-being strategies the same space and
plus common sorry is we obviously have
our five deep dive areas that we went
through last year each with a Smart
Action Plan each with a set deliverables
and Targets in there so again we've got
rich information that we can bring
through there we should be and will be
part of
an updates at the meetings that they
have so um not to forget those as well
thank you
that's very important that it's going to
do some really interesting points we
can't you know we've got to keep our
priorities
because the thing that you know you
can't get bogged down with all the stuff
that's going on so and thanks for
raising them again Tom and if we move on
then to item eight it's a system working
towards hardening qualities
myself
onto the screen and thanks for
um but what we wanted to do this morning
is kind of get the board thinking about
housing equalities and how we can affect
health and qualities as a board and we
recognize that there's huge amounts of
work going on across Hanford around
health and quality but it's just having
that oversight and the impact that we
need to be having as a system really at
the moment
um so we do have an updated slider
um we've been thinking this has been
quite um an organic process to get to
this point in terms of the slides
there's been lots of discussions within
our team that required for partners as
well so
um I'll be asking a Partners to
contribute to the section at the end as
well so you do have a question again not
slido but we'll go old school and
actually have a discussion about them
but it's okay for Friday morning so Kate
go on to the next slide
so this kind of demonstrates I think
pre-candemic
the health and well-being board and
Trafford has always been thinking about
health inequality it's been something
obviously that is fundamental to our
Public Health practice but as an
organization we have been really
conscious of it and I think the Trafford
in particular
you know our outcomes in general are
really good but we have some real really
difficult inequalities that sit below
our outcome outcomes that really impact
on our population
um but post pandemic you can see that
this is just a selection of some of
these strategies and some of the
documents that are currently driving all
the partners around the table so we've
got the NHS and programs of work the
core 20 and then we've got a low
Collective board and we've got our
health well-being priorities as well
it's a real kind of um
range of work that we we also need to
know to the mom at work as well in first
Society healthier lives which is really
important driver particularly for public
health work thanks Kate
so just that we start with just
just clarifying what we mean by Health
inequality so Health inequalities are
avoidable in systematic differences in
health between different groups of
people and this is how we would classify
them so if you look at the four
different areas different social
economic groups and deprivation we will
be thinking about our smoking rates
within our routine manual workers
compared to our our wider population and
we know that people who smoke have got
worth Health outcomes protected
characteristics so if we think about our
people our residents are serious mental
illness
um this isn't this for me is a metric
that
is a really sobering metric car because
there's all those people serious mental
illness in Trafford
um are likely to die from physical
health conditions 20 years younger than
people without a serious mental illness
so that's a real real consideration for
US geography if we look at our residency
living Partington compare tourists and
to live in Hale and then inclusion
health and vulnerable groups if you
think about
um our residents who live within
domestic abuse refuges or our traveler
populations as well so there are just
some examples to bring it to life it's
been hand over to Kate now with some
more inequality evidence okay
thank you right so this looks a very
messy and colorful slider bear with me
this is the product of
um I suppose a few years really of
thinking about and talking to colleagues
in different organizations and in
different Partnerships a bit like this
about health inequalities and realizing
how overwhelming it can be as a place to
be thinking and trying to work out what
your role is
um for various different people
particularly when we think about all of
the
um reports and policy and strategy and
anything else that we've reflected on
the beginning
um so I started to think about what does
all the evidence have in common how does
it all fit together what what are we
trying to say and none of this will come
as a great surprise to any of you but I
just found it has been useful in other
conversations to refresh our
understanding kind of the logic model
how what are we all trying to do and how
do we think what we're doing is going to
achieve some change for people in the
end so this is a very simple simple kind
of representation of some of the
evidence around the drivers of
and life expectancy particularly
um and a reminder that obviously the
things that are that make us healthy are
the things that lead to inequalities
because of the way they're distributed
so and here we've got the fact that and
you've got your kind of socioeconomic
conditions and the things that Marmot
really Drew attention to and lots of
other policy work is designed to to
influence policy we just have the
housing strategy it's a really good
example of the kind of core drivers that
really make the biggest difference to um
outcomes for people and including the
inequalities in those outcomes but also
education and fundamental things like
Community relationships and how people
feel about those
um but those things impact on
um the kind of ability the the options
we've got in the way we live our lives
to kind of and what we might call Health
behaviors is a bit of debate about some
of the language there but and the
opportunity we have physically actually
um to eat healthily to smoke and how we
use alcohol and those four at lifestyle
pains the health behaviors refer to them
drive before big Clinic conditions
death worldwide has just reminding us
that that
there's some in a simplistic way there's
actually some really big hitters that we
know and can focus on at the evidence
shows us and the other things that I've
added in there typically kind of model
that's on the left there which is from
the who is the fact that obviously those
things also impact significant young
people's quality of life and morbidity
not just death
so breaking that down a little bit and I
will go through this a little bit faster
because we want to have time for a
discussion but you'll get these
afterwards and so I'm hoping it's going
to help retaining the decision so if you
start at the the end of the model the
orange bit and just click the reflecting
on outcomes and I should expectancy in
Trafford some of you will have seen this
a version of this uh slide show
um at the health and social care
Steering group where we talked about a
gap in a life expectancy for the
um 20 cents it took up into we've looked
and broken it down now by the top and
bottom 10 in terms of decoration in
Trafford and that is a bigger Gap
because obviously you're talking about
the extremes there of deprivation and so
the Gap in traffic is at 9.5 years for
male life expectancy
um and 7.2 now 30 years for female life
expectancy that's the gap between most
deprived 10 and there you can see and
the other thing to take I think from
that slide is that
um there hasn't been really much of a
change and that International picture of
a plateau in life expectancy and in some
areas actually a decrease
um but that yeah that can change and the
Gap hasn't really changed much either
so going back is that what the immediate
causes of that Gap and life expectancy
sometimes we get stuck on obviously this
bit but
um it's an important part of the steps
so we've got some quite good information
about what what
um clinical conditions or what so what
causes the death and usually cause of
death contributes to the Gap in life
expectancies they includes your medical
causes but it also includes your
external causes for your trauma
um so that's what countries have a death
not what we saw to the Gap so in other
countries called deaths certainly and so
that's really important to our clients
to understand where they that Gap in
life expectancy is coming from
how that's changed over time which has
obviously particularly been
improve it and but the other breakdown
hasn't changed much
um and obviously those those um
conditions and causes of death are um
cause illness and poor quality of life
and that varies by geography so this is
where the inequalities come in and this
is self-reported Health by ethnicity
from census and see
um
sorry that's the geography one and then
we've got um values by population group
as well so that's Helen alluded to
um we've got information about groups of
people with for example severe mental
illness who are much more likely to have
a physical health conditions than the
general population
so you can look at things like your
field by population groups
in terms of those immediate causes going
back a step those immediate causes of
death are obviously um significantly
impacted as we said by
um behaviors Healthcare is the
opportunities to to be um to be well or
to be physically active and there's
there's um data there on the
um obesity by ethnicity and physical
inactivity by ethnicity that's just
another example of the variation in uh
opportunities to
manage those risk factors
so that's another place that we can
Target work
and the obvious important driver which
isn't Stokely still the number one cause
of preventable deaths on Earth and it
used to live uh
um so we just had some very very new
data released and uh
just released and showing a decrease in
traffic to eight percent of smoking from
11 which is absolutely good for news and
but we still have that um those
inequalities there so again important to
look at the surface of those figures
um particularly the our nature series
mental illness has actually increased
um to 42 in the most recent data and so
that's something that we'd really want
to have a look at could be an area of
focus for
his work going forward and the routine
manual workers and category which is
another way that we break down
data
um has actually decreased as well which
is which is really good and useful
and on the right some information
actually said let's just demonstrate
some of the evidence we've got our
fingertips
and then if you go back to that first
step of life on the left of the logic
model the reasons why people can't lift
those healthy lives are complex and
intertwined with their health so as an
example we've got an information about
adult carers and having as much Social
contact to say the right so she has a
really mixed set of reasons why and that
would be the case and but it's an
interesting one for us because actually
at the lower end compared to similar
areas in terms of those people having
that contact so again actually in those
kind of areas will make a big difference
all the way along
so I suppose the point in general is we
need to work at the different levels of
that diagram between us or in order to
make sustainable changes and
and some of those kind of more immediate
causes and you've got the need to do
that as well as well as the other two
levels
so hopefully that's helpful for you to
think about where your
internalization role is for less and the
interventions you're involved in sit
so what's happening in Trafford with
this and I'm going to go through this is
just to give you a sense a bit like the
policy strategy documents
um that there's a lot going on in
Trafford obviously you'll be involved in
lots more than this as well
um and so I think the point that we're
making here is
um that it's
there's probably some work to do it
feels like to us now anyway we bought
this item here and in the descriptions
we've had various review about
um helping as well as assistant to see
where where we're working well on some
of these things and where their live
gaps
and possibly to help Focus
um on a few key
um debates today
um so just going back to the same thing
um and again this has made you something
to reflect on data but I've tried to fit
some of our Trafford and core priorities
and core pieces of work into that logic
model to help us to see
um how it fits together and I suppose
that the job would be to expand on this
and to really make it with us and think
about what else is out there so it's
kind of a starting point to share with
you that was helping me as I was going
through this
so really really interested in your
reflection Sports and obviously a lot
more
and the other really important part of
course to think about in terms of what's
going on in Trafford is in terms of more
delivery which is why I haven't included
it specifically anywhere there do you
think it kind of sits under the whole
lot doesn't it
um if the neighborhood model that
mentioned obviously and at most of our
discussions because they're really
positive work that's going on to make
sure that we're reflecting those
neighborhood Arrangements priorities
needs
um sits underneath all of this and so
understanding how
that kind of looking at the various
steps whilst also taking into account
the differences and using some of the
great work that's going on and the
infrastructure that's developing in
neighborhoods I think that would be the
key
board so we wanted to give you an
example because
um a really good question that came up
in the previous discussion at one of the
Health and Social care steering groups
was
that's gray Theory and strategy and
bring it all together but maybe that's
helpful but can you give us an example
of how we make it real and what this
might actually mean for people so if
this thought's a really good opportunity
to share for Joe to share some of the
work that she's been doing on a
um relatively small
um piece of Public Health commission a
drink that's joined with um lmq and the
ICB now and so as an example of that so
come outside
great thanks and so this example really
looks at how we're addressing that
Health behaviors element and the health
inequalities on one of the previous
slides and so we've had some funding in
public health and together with some
funding from lnq and that for a project
that we've run for a few years now which
has been addressing some of those
specific groups in Trafford that face
those greater inequalities in health and
so these are the common projects that
we've got as you can see uh they all
look to Target specific groups like The
Deaf Community a healthy diverse
communities and people with learning
disabilities and sensory impairment but
we can't assume that a few years on that
those gaps and that they're still the
groups in greatest need so we needed
see what would be important to deliver
for the next few years in the future so
you just go to the first slide so this
is the process that we've undertaken so
the very very first thing we did and I
think it's important to mention that
this was the first thing we did is we
went out and we spoke to the voluntary
sector and communities and worked with
George
um through the
um through the work there with the
neighborhoods and went to speak to the
collective before we had any idea so in
some of those first meetings people ask
me questions and I'll say I don't know
and I think that's good because then I
think they could see that in fact they
were saying we haven't thought that
through yet we're coming into you at the
very very beginning to talk about this
project before it's actually shaped so
we went out to like age UK super social
we went round to all of the collective
and neighborhoods and we got some really
interesting views from them on What
mattered around Health inequalities and
what they thought so it was things like
joint working removing barriers for
people the impact of services and access
and out of hours mental health came up
and financial situations attracted
people and cost of living using those
Community assets digital exclusion
particularly in older people and having
community outreach so obviously that's a
huge amount of kind of need and we're
not really going to completely solve
that with our 145 000 pound fund but um
I can certainly share the detailed
feedback for you because on a system
level we do need to look at and
understand what those barriers are
so that was the first stage the second
bit was then we went out to speak to our
partners so obviously had conversations
with Ellen Q spoke to Toms spoke to
George and lco uh went and spoke to the
neighborhood leads there spoke to
um the ICB in terms of their long-term
conditions the primary care inequalities
group and we spoke to Paul nethercott
from nft
um mental health Commissioners early
Health Commissioners strategic housing
we spoke to homelessness and service we
spoke to our internal equalities uh
thank you heather for the feedback that
we got on the needs assessment from
healthwatch we went out and spoke to a
broad range of Partners around the
project that we're doing we then held a
learning event with um partners and the
volunteering Community sector using
something called the Combee model and
what this model does is it looks at what
is actually stopping people from
changing their behavior and what types
of interventions might help so it looks
at the opportunities people have to
change their behavior their motivation
and what might impact that and whether
they're capable of making those changes
really interesting through lots of stuff
around cultural norms but also Community
norms and the importance of your peers
do they also smoke will they support you
if you stop smoking the fear of the
unknown I've always done this and I
don't know whether I you know I can I
can kind of stop and the lack of
understanding of your best well I feel
all right I feel quite healthy you know
not really understanding what's best the
stigma of actually using Services
professional apathy and I mean that came
for an example around mental health is
smoking the biggest thing to deal with
when you're in the middle of um you know
an episode of psychosis misconceptions
and real barriers around things like
time money communication needs and that
it's really difficult to change what you
do
false sense of security well I'm not
overweight so I don't think I'm that
unhealthy
um and really struck routines that
you're used to doing things in certain
ways
lots of good ideas about targeting
services to specific populations or even
specific people in family units in
particular cultures into particular
communities who is it in that family
that's really important is it the dad
that's making the decisions is it the
mum that's making the decisions are they
looking to the children to kind of lead
the way in terms of behavior change and
stuff around using regular people can if
you want to change your behavior if you
hear a story from somebody that kind of
feels a bit like me that looks like
they've come from my neighborhood I
might listen to them more than a
professional telling me and what I need
to do taking services to people
education making things affordable
flexibility of services helping people
to have reality checks to understand
what their health risks are peer support
and simplifying the eligibility of
services so really good stuff that I can
take on board with this specific project
but I think the health and well-being
board can take on boards and more wider
we did a health needs assessment to look
at those inequality so going back to
some of those earlier slides we looked
at which of those groups are over then
presented in like conditions like
diabetes which groups are more likely to
be inactive which groups are more likely
to smoke what are those risk factors and
who do they affect more than other
people and we came up with a long list
of needs and we've got a separate full
presentation on that needs assessment so
we looked at what the needs are and what
those groups were and then we did a gap
analysis to look at well what have we
actually already got in Trafford what
services are already working and working
with those particular groups of people
where we could do some improvements and
decided that the best approach was to
look at the where we already have
services in prey in place to try and
enhance that service with interventions
within that service that might support
Behavior change and then where we didn't
have those services in place that's what
we're going to commission out for those
gaps and so for example Blue Sky gmmh
we're doing a load of work right now
with our stop smoking interventions so
great let's let's do that within those
services that already exist homelessness
service I mean obviously there's um
these uh health drop-ins so let's use
the nurse there to do health checks to
do smoking cessation and then we'll pay
for those interventions through our
Public Health budget and social housing
we're looking at a smoking cessation
project there and building on things
like the carers health checks that were
already being taken place through the
carer center looking at Leisure Services
looking at and what probation are doing
and some new posts they've got there and
the proud trust LGBT foundation so some
of what we're going to do is we're going
to enhance what exists already and but
some of that also leaves us with some
areas of Gap
so for the groups that are in the where
we don't have a strong service already
in place we're looking for them to help
us to identify those patients that are
at highest risk when looking at them to
positively engage with them to try and
see if they can engage with the
preventative Services that actually are
already out there and then if they can't
we're then looking to for them to
develop replacement bespoke services for
that particular Community or group and
then at the same time we want them to
support all of those services in the
system around what system changes need
to happen so that they can have a role
in gathering that feedback through next
slide
so these are the groups that we're going
to focus on with this fund where we feel
there is a gap still and we need to
um perhaps have some specific project
doing those things on the previous slide
and these are the outcomes that of
interest to us which I'm sure are very
much of interest to you at the health
and well-being board and so I kind of
hope you can see from this example that
on a small scale how it is integrated
across Services how it is supporting
those system-wide issues and changes
around inequalities and most importantly
the same time it's making a difference
to the people who face those greatest
barriers and difficulties within our
community
thanks Joe so that's a really good
example so we've kind of set the ground
uh what What's you know the issues that
we're facing in Trafford and then Joseph
is a really good example of what we do
in public health is a reasonably small
budget really but to make a big impact
on some of our inequalities so we've
come to the board really to ask the boys
and the system what approach should we
take but there are a couple of things we
need to consider so some interventions
that improve overall population health
and actually make health and quantities
um was so if you think about
you know we often have that worried well
model so if we all get invited to the
NHS health check there will be a
population that will Rush book their NHS
health check and have that nhf as NHS
health check until it's Friday I can't
speak
um and they they will often be those
people who are able to do that and are
reasonably well and fit at the same with
cancer screening there is a real risk at
a population level of making inequality
um bigger by not addressing and not
working with our populations to to
encourage that uptake man
often actually
um working with various people I've had
to do the highest overall burden of
disease is more effective than um those
at risk highest inequality so to speak
about people who are obese already or
you have heard of heart attack often
they'll be more open to to working and
to
um Behavior change
but proportionate universalism is
something I think is a Trafford
organization and a system we really need
to think about so what we mean there is
targeting at the greatest need rather
than
um
having having a population level
approach targeting everybody
um across the whole of our Borough to
change Behavior actually looking at the
evidence of Joe's presented and Kate's
presented if we focus in on this
particular geography and this particular
group then it's it's about really
focusing our efforts and addressing the
inequality okay
so if I'm into some questions really so
I wanted this this presentation to be
more of a conversation to get people
thinking so what did the board to think
about do we focus on a few key
population groups causes and experiences
and if so which and how do we decide
what these are
we've got the health well-being
priorities which I'm sure you all know
of my heart
um
do we need to identify specific
inequality and interventions to focus on
within those so do we just want to have
some stretch targets underneath our our
inequalities
do we need a tactical group to align
programs provide Challenge and identify
opportunities
of presentation this week on making
Manchester fairer which is a really
interesting way of working that they
have in Manchester but we need to
recognize that our resources are
different introvert and could we stand
up a different approach in traffic to
really coordinate in focusing on
inequalities across the whole of the
system okay and then how do we
capitalize on the planned refresh of the
locality board and the health and
well-being strategy to really have that
impact on tackling inequalities
so thank you
okay thank you all it was very
interesting and if you can share those
with the slides that we really helpful
and so if we could if people want to
have a chat around
and where they think we should be going
with with this I think that for me I
think that what we need to be looking at
is that those that are at risk of having
to go into Hospital in those sort of
situations that you need to be making
sure that we're planning so that we're
able to support those people before they
get home hospitalized because we don't
want patients we want residents so I
think that it's really important that we
look at some of that sort of stuff does
anybody else have any how much reaching
foreign
deaths were from population groups that
had two or three long-term conditions
and actually if we'd had the health of
our population even better we would have
had less a lot less covered depth so I
think it's just something to bear in
mind when we're presented with the cause
of death but behind that it's more
complicated isn't it but I'm sure
colleagues here will will know that and
then I think the other thing for me in
terms of what we do my thoughts would be
I think you know Public Health
population Health Services business
isn't it so that should be we should
challenge the that's in everything we do
I know for Helen and I with our
community health teams for children and
adults the screening
it's like to do when they first meet
people and directing to services so I
think there's a challenge there but we
all do that and then the final thing for
me it's just I'm really struck by the 20
early death for people with slowly joint
mental health problems and I don't I
feel very strongly and I've worked
because it worked in leadership over the
Mental Health Trust for 10 years so I
know how difficult it is and I don't
think we should be leaving this to
annual GP checks and very very busy busy
services that are overrun by the cube
crises and if you look at um
at that group we know that they will
have all had adverse childhood
experiences probably a Full House of
trauma is a particular key uh key factor
foreign
if we can look together as providers
about how we can get around that
particular group of people and start to
bend the curve on it
everybody else
uh Heather
and the experience of careers and
multiple
Roman versus one and property is another
you'll see one of the biggest drawings
is through Medical Health
[Music]
um
and then if we want people to go and
receive services
[Music]
are also include children because there
are lots of children who are really
position allowed to care for parents and
they are almost overpassive audits
really not just
and
[Music]
so one of the points I was going to make
was it was about carers and whether
there's a carer strategy and then my
second point was going through a
conversation right for me about
um individuals with mental health I've
also added that and individuals with
learning disability in terms of what we
know about about early life
and there will be some learning already
in the system through the local media
reviews
and
community
also one of the projects that we've
currently funded Empower you has
specifically looked at um people with
learning disabilities and not only has
it looked to address things like
physical inactivity which then lead on
to uh likelihood of developing or the
health conditions but they've worked
with people themselves to help them to
become more healthy but then also done
some work with the providers themselves
so kind of body support for people with
learning disabilities to help them to
understand the importance of the of the
health needs and for people to be
healthier and then alongside that have
worked with mainstream services and that
are providing for the general population
to help them to be more accessible for
people with learning disability it's
been a really really important project
and has worked with a vast number of
people and been quite a success so we'd
want to see something along those lines
continuing in Trafford
certainly kind of books that prevents
the way of working on the map
I think echoing had that having focused
piece of work probably the way forward
because that will then allow us to have
tangible changes that will help you
support those people who are affected by
if you're thinking about the NHS culture
because at the moment it's available to
people who overthought me and we know
that people from an ethnic background
like they use if you call
getting these diseases earlier on so I'm
just wondering what what juices there
are suppose in terms of capturing these
people earlier and starting up
preventative work and therefore
reducing the impact on the system later
on time
and so we've currently got a pilot
project with Pakistani Resource Center
looking at targeting and it's together
with I think it's north Trafford group
practice looking to see if we do health
checks at an earlier age for certain
ethnicities what the impact of that will
be so it will be good to see how that
pilot pans out and to see whether that's
something that we need to do on a wider
level
yeah
I suppose specifically as well as that
and we've got a project being from the
through the ICD where we're going to be
targeting the different diverse
community in the north to look at
long-term conditions generally I think
the key there which Associates
we are working with organizations in the
area for a long time
so the interventions and the
conversations have been being had at an
individual Community level
I think that's one of the things that's
really important because presentation
and it makes very much really honestly
communication strategy and irrigating
strategy really high times to me to talk
to people about what works for them to
take a look that jobs was Frank it's
been based on what are people telling us
the safety the value of that it also
gives you that opportunity to think
about how would you do to things
differently because we all know when
this time and we're not going to get any
more money to think about what's the
culture look like how do you do things
if anything that's going to be really
important for us
to say unfortunately
because that's the only way
so I just think it's a really good
presentation really challenges that's
the early area for me I think we've got
a lot of information we don't need to
leave
them and clearly around the inequalities
have some workers
and employers
describe the differences
thanks
thank you
thank you um so just a definite I think
support for myself at least
um
lots of different things
um but I actually do think there needs
to be a dedicated Focus for this piece
of work you can see how it's just
mobilize the conversation after people
in this room
just probably had about four or five
specific examples of some amazing
working communities that's happening
that's having a real difference and but
I'm not too sure we've got that fully
mapped out and understood what every
single partner in this room is doing
towards the agenda so I think that's a
practical thing we can do by picking you
up in a group not as maybe as ground as
making Manchester Fair because of the
resourcing issues ETC but something of
that help
um
I do think this goes back to the things
that a golden touch throughout the
conversation which is the power of the
neighborhood model and the integrative
working communities in particular how
local intelligence comes through that
neighborhood model and the effects that
enable the plans which are disposed to
the needs and aspirations of the
individual communities that make up our
neighborhoods and therefore targeting
the available results as a system into
those four areas
um so I think there's links here for me
to the engagement framework that we want
to put in place for Trafford integrated
care partnership at the natural
strategic level when we're taking a
conversation that's a locality Hall next
week so yeah real support for everything
you've just said hello thanks
yeah
okay
um just a couple of questions for me
obviously the presentation was
um very clear intense being data light
and data intelligence and I think that's
really important sense and secondly the
other part of the conversation has been
we've heard about a lot about the number
of pilots and as well as being data
intelligence I think we need to couple
that with being evidence-based because
actually we've talked about resources
being quite scarce
it's really important that we understand
what works and what the basis and what
works that doesn't mean to say we do the
same as we've always done but there is
something about being evidence-based in
in sales I think Richard's point about
comorbidities have to be later covered
but that point about actually what do we
understand not just about particular
groups of the population will the
clustering of a particular Health
inequalities difficulties Aces being one
of those examples really and if we
combine those things together then we do
have a a strong approach for when we do
need to Target
get slightly nervous when we talk about
the neighborhoods because in some
neighborhoods particularly in the South
you know we have some muscatives some of
those inequalities so we have pockets
within neighborhoods so again thinking
about the drill down and what the data
actually tells us and what we understand
by it is probably very important links
to that point about the voice of the
community so welcome the approach and
just to come back later in terms of your
question about catering strategy we also
within that strategy have
um dedicated approach in terms of young
carers and we do have a dedicated lead
for you and carers
thank you
and yeah I'm really drawn to
um okay we are starting to
kind of remainder of the three
key behavioral changes to the health and
well-being strategy
um we've been taught so we've touched
upon them to a degree in maintenance
I've seen given our positive resources
and the fact about action if you look
around the room you've got lots and lots
of
organizations
it's just really enforcing those
messages and making sure about the
principles of the making everything
so we ask those questions to ask
questions and people might say voluntary
if I can go about what we're asking the
question
because we have come back as an
extension Workforce when we look at
particularly objects on particular teams
perhaps more so it's just just really
impossible
and
you know
so I was just going to suggest
online support and how we could have our
making traffic fair over um our
partnership that
supports this program of work and
consolidates what's going on with the
African space and evaluation as well
which I think is what were these things
I think Joe's example is there's lots of
work going on I just wanted to thank
Jill as well because her team have
turned that piece of commission around
incredibly quickly into really high
quality but it is about us having that
evaluations and knowing what works and
how every moment of the board can
contribute to inequality across traffic
so I'm happy to bring the proposal to
the next board
thank you
um
ask you to approve the recommendations A
to Z so it was approved if anybody can
be done more often than us
I take it they are thank you so much
then
okay
thank you
[Music]
hi everyone here thank you very much
okay
so um this is a presentation of the
annual report of the charters overview
panel
um which uh quite recently received from
the chair of the panel
um so just a bit of background if anyone
who doesn't know
um the child of therapy panels are a
statutory partnership where they are um
working together guidance
um and they are to bring together
Partners to review and every child death
um to bring together kind of population
information and then identify trends
that might help us prevent this in the
future and they um support that day to
get supported nationally to the
um
and we also gather that obviously
locally for
um Trafford we have a tripartite panel
with um teamside and Stockport and
Manchester has its own panel and very
much download and have a uh panel and
self when we didn't have a check outside
panel as well
um ours is shared at the moment by the
public health consultant in Stockport
and that rotates every couple of years
there between the three areas
um so it's important to note that the
reviews that the charter therapy panel
and conduct take place after any kind of
other substitute with review or inquiry
so obviously any people inquiry any
safeguarding and review so they are
often reviewed quite a bit later after
the death for some of those
um and the panels made up of um
we represent their their profession so
they're not necessarily the
professionals involved in the individual
death which is again different to
responds to the individual case
um this in this annual report like uh
like the previous annual report has
quite small numbers so I would say take
uh taking I've taken all of this uh the
findings of some
um caution but there is a um
the programs work to enable a five-year
review in 24 25 and because at the see
the system is now being put in place so
that will allow us to have the data on
more robust to putting amongst the three
but also
um I think really important as well to
do that across the GM footprint and
allows some of the analysis of some of
those lower incidents
trends
um
the recommendations are fairly
consistent year on year and for the use
of the computer supports but we'll come
to those in a minute
uh just also before I'd dive into the
report and so she said in your packs and
you have got the actual report and
you've got a cover note where I've
highlighted
um some of the
um findings and some of the
recommendations and also included in
that cover note
um for our traffic just got initial
response to those recommendations that
gives you a sense of some of the
um activity that's going on to address
some of those that we've gathered kind
of fairly quickly but obviously I'm very
keen to hear
um how it fit into anybody else's work
but it's uncovered that
um so just going back to this uh had a
look at the infant and child mortality
rates
um for Trafford and these are done on
two
for the data points to transmute them up
into bits obviously they are quite small
numbers thankfully
um you can see the infant mortality rate
has had a big drop and the last two
while in data points which is good great
news obviously infant mortality being a
deaths of children one in this case and
the child mortality rate which is for
one to 17 year olds and up a look a bit
actually for each other so that's
something that
um we can have a bit more of a look at
um amongst partners because there's
obviously other sources of information
on what's going on there they are very
small numbers for a year
if there's anything that's
um statistically significant
we can work on
um so we'll come to some of that just a
bit of uh infographic representation of
what you've got in the report already
and so for 39 deaths notified
um in 2122 that's across the three areas
and
um that is below the eight year average
but there isn't yet a clear Trend
towards any lower road to mate or
anything we're not yet able to call that
um
so those are six quarters or so
um of the deaths were in babies 28 days
so it was really neonatal
um deaths
um and so obviously as a proportion of
being
um a number of live birth and a number
of babies in that age group that is
obviously a higher rate than the older
age group you make up the largest
language remember
um so the causes of death
um are mainly chromosomal genetic
incandescent abnormalities which affect
both those under ones and some of the
slightly older children so that
that would come in there and should see
so these sudden unexpected and
unexplained death where there is no
cause
these are taken from those 39 notified
deaths that again they're quite they're
quite small numbers but the five year
analysis will enable us to see
um a bit more on that
there's a lot more detail in the report
obviously but I did
um uh pick out so in terms of some of
those older age uh young people who have
died those children so they have died
and there's some some of them are sort
of cancers come up and Trauma of course
so accidents and assaults where those
occurs small numbers but they're there
and some of those later effects of the
same genetic and
deprivation uh there is a patron but
it's um in the the
um the 6th of eight from 19 to 22 so it
does use a few years worth of
notifications that we've had the it's
not a straight line gradient and there
is an increase in the risk for those in
the most required groups
and this is a bit more up and down again
a five-year analysis will give us
that
okay
and then what the panel does
when it does come to the panel and have
this full review one of the questions
that we have to ask and report on is a
judgment about whether the date had
modifiable factors
um which might have meant that in other
circumstances the death could be
avoidable so that's a really difficult
decision
um with plant business significant
guidance around that but it's a
professional judgment and discussion of
course that goes on there to try and
make a consistent decision so as you can
see for the under ones slightly lower
proportion uh considered to have
modifiable factors than for the older
children
um perhaps in surprisingly of those that
did have modifiable factors and they
these are the kinds of things that came
out most commonly and that is
consistently previous year's findings
um so the reason that things like
smoking uh will come up particularly it
will be about smoking and pregnancy
partly and so at least in the first day
of birth rate deaths Mutual ladies
so
um recommendations for 21 and 22 include
that we should continue work and these
recommendations home will be made
consistently for the three areas as
chair of the panel recommendations
um that we should continue work to
address those long-standing known causes
for increased risk child deaths and
we've been particularly younger
children's deaths and these include
um obesity including particularly for
women at childbearing age
um smoking by pregnant women and
household members parental drug and
alcohol use domestic abuse has come up
this year mental ill health co-sleeping
which and there's been a subject of
safeguarding action in the past and also
consistent last year this one about
multiple embryo implantation which has
been taken up with colleagues at the Geo
maternity system and others
guidance and regulation
providers
then we've got some specific actions for
maternity work around access to high
quality and student care from early in
pregnancies and safe and evidence-based
healthy weight intervention is
everything above
um which we have picked up with our
maternity colleagues
um so in the uh report uh the cover note
that you've got
um and given a kind of summary of some
of the actions already in place to
address these as I say these are
relatively consistent PPC is so it was
ongoing work but it's also reinforced
given us some evidence for some more
focusing some of our work and we picked
up uh particularly things like our place
with maternity services in our healthy
weights doctor too and making sure that
those those are in place in service
rooms and families needs and the other
recommendations there are around
ensuring robust data recording uh
particularly around ethnicity and
characteristics and equality and really
important and limits our ability to
identify Trends or to identify what
early might work needs to work if you
don't record that comes up everywhere
you look around inequalities I know so
just reinforcing that within the
organizations helpful
um
manager salary I should have introduced
Shelly is here to observe this item and
obviously can't answer any without the
process surely that manages the process
of the three areas and obviously she
does a lot of work to try and identify
information to do these reviews
[Applause]
um there's an accommodation about
housing chair Works which I've taken in
detail here because I don't think you
need that here
um and that the annual report will be
produced
so I stopped there there was obviously a
lot more in the report that's that's
detailed I wanted to just present a bit
with somebody on slide which you haven't
had yet so I can circulate
okay
um
this or too many um
some of the practices we can support to
mitigate our ones that we've been
talking about in our qualities and we've
already qualities and stuff so you know
if you need to do a lot more focus on
making sure that our children get the
rights out so yeah
just two quick questions for me one of
us really um pleased to see
um that there were some actions for our
maternity Services both from a
preventative perspective really and
having those conversations at the
earliest stage I just wondered though
obviously you know some of our maternity
services are on an improvement Journey
so it was just some think about
assurance and an understanding about
following through on not just their
recommendations for all of the
recommendations in the overview reports
because there's um councils later said
it it's a really serious issue obviously
it's a tragedy for anybody dying and the
same themes and issues and to come out
from the annual reports I know they're
distorted because of the low numbers to
some extent of course they are the same
themes and issues that come out so that
was my first long-winded question really
about assurance and following through on
the actions the second one was
um less so this year in previous years
we have also sadly had
um some deaths by Suicide and I just
wondered about the cross-referencing
with the child death overview process
and the suicide prevention processes and
what whether there's any joint learning
from looking at those things together
processes but it has been a live
discussion recently as well as with the
job related death overview panel which
says which is another process that goes
on
um so as you say small it will always be
something small numbers
um but there's definitely opportunities
for both
um gather the right information for the
case views to have them but also then to
make sure that those
um that are built into the
recommendations I don't know if you've
got specific examples
recommendations picked up but just be
here for the maternity questions so we
now work closely with Sue McCauley who's
our Public Health
um we tendency but
maternity within greater Manchester
um
managed through the ICB and we
commissioned through Manchester
Commissioners rather than traffic
conditions so that relies on that
relationship
some of the work has gone on across and
I didn't show at the moment interruption
in particular around outcomes maternity
um in terms of suicide it's very like
discussion at the moment we have a
really active Council players are
chairperson Suicide Prevention board
really active to do celebration board
um and lots of work on going at the
moment and just to assure people the
great contractors are very stable we're
not seeing any increases until tonight
fortunately uh so that's that's where
you should work again similar to child
death that makes suicide it is an
absolute tragedy where it occurs with
children
um we have it's called a community
response plan so it's an immediate as
soon as we're notified so Public Health
receive real suicide data comes from the
Corolla usually within 24 hours of
notification of concerns or suspected
suicide and where they're under 18 or
within a group that that could be at a
high risk from contagion as we call it
we would be familiar I guess we'll call
it mmt Agency Group around that
particular case so um with the school or
assembly Tevin College the college would
be there the any air Community groups
that are part of that your person's life
you think about social media and you
think about groups that they belong to
um School nursing and mental health but
looking to see what we can do to support
those people affected by that suicide
and also reduce risk amongst their peers
and colleagues as well so
um we've had three
profiles completed since 2020 it's been
a really important and Powerful process
um to really understand what's happened
in most situations
but it has a serious enough prevention
and absolute priority for us and it pays
in the seed up but we haven't had a
young person serious about it in the
last 12 months I don't think I agree
there was a number that wasn't there in
2021 unfortunately
foreign
maternity and um we are getting together
with the other three
um other public health leads for
children and Seed up in the other areas
because we see we do these are
tripartite level but anybody has a seat
and they'll come out similar
recommendations everyone asked for some
of those maternity Services particularly
to take that paper and and the request
of our Assurance to the uh local
internal system board which does have
representation from public health and
from other other Representatives but not
necessarily our area so we don't sit on
ourselves in traffic but we've got to
just figure that out I think
insurance as you say
yeah so hopefully there's one thing you
know the small number of death to all of
these things
especially
um
any of those
you know
put anything increases
so their their diet while being born and
picked up some of this in terms of that
living one age group and obesity smoking
alcoholism every day are some of the key
factors that
um
result in core outcomes about babies and
being more in poor conditions that
absolutely take that on board in terms
of how we link it all together maybe
without regular free service but it is
that for example with obesity
um if a woman
um becomes an unhealthy weight in the
first pregnancy then that's only going
to continue throughout because we know
that as
um scanning a baby it becomes more
difficult as obviously becomes an issue
so these are really key and life issues
for our services at the moment that that
Kate will be focusing on
yeah
and
very powerful I think um sort of looking
at the risk specification through the
morning when you probably expect me to
sort of say it a bit sort of physical
inactivity
um and I just wonder sort of as the Deep
asking done into drug and alcohol the
likelihood is inactivity with showers as
well and then we've got the data
alongside and we don't know the
difference between adult and children
but we do know that one in six in the UK
that's a cause or attributed to
inactivity and then if we go back to the
earlier conversation around you know
that
where the services are between children
and adults we know that in Trafford 70
of our children and young people are not
meeting the guidelines on physical
activity
um for the first time tips into not not
just where we see it normally in
decoration but that trend is is growing
so it was just an observation really
um I don't think it will tell us
anything at all but I suppose the
inactivity intrinsically linked to the
other lifestyle
um risk factors
you know important to talk about you
James about people before the pregnant
you know teenagers how do we support
them
and so if we can note the sign off of
the report
um
very challenging topic thank you very
much Kelly um
so
and we have submitted the template
um and the narrative plan through the
regional Assurance process and Marine
Parts where the license reported into
this board and it's subsequently gone
through that successfully and now into
the national process has been approved
and he raised very much better of
integration between adult social care
and the ICP
and increasingly a lot of government
grants pertaining to discharge
especially reference the best capital of
America across cross reference content
so a really key document for US 36
um million pounds a line from the within
the section 75 degree with the legal
agreement we have between the United
Council we also have to build funds for
learning disabilities which is outside
the national and town
something we chosen to do in Trafford
there's a number of conditions which are
referenced in the relative plan
and we have a number of metrics which
will refer to our own in the united
performance framework and I hope that is
agency arrangement for outbreak
management across Trafford it describes
the world's responsibility of speech
partner
um there's some key tasks so if we look
at part two for example it really sets
down who does what who swaps you
describes who manages whatever element
of the particular steps and then some
consideration into particular
um outbreaks it also describes what we
should have an outbreak control team and
when we don't have an accurate control
too so it's a really clear kind of
framework to work from it's been
reviewed by each of the locality
outbreak control plans has been reviewed
by the GMS system and we have a great
positive feedback and we've addressed
any recommendations that we made so it's
um robust in terms of the GM
recommendations all Partners signs the
trust your opportunity board that
includes
um primary care and other colleagues and
so we just bring it here today to find
the phone being broadcasting Health
protection laws and things through
through governance into Health while
being good
thank you
such a hugely important government
especially what you think
I think this you know what happens
before
um
I know that Helen's going to give us a
quick update on Kobe after this item so
does anybody else have any questions
okay
designer
thank you all very much and yes one
active an aov that's reported civils and
it's howling to give you some
information around covered I'm not sure
what number we're up to you know
we're talking about it
no experts me to say it's covered
whatever and while we're getting the
people who want to go to the marketplace
so
um
just to bring members of speed so
um to boxer the UK Health Security
Agency are monitoring the new variant
which is known as VA
0.2.86 variant
um and the issue really at the moment is
because of the lack of testing in
communities the understanding of the
growth of variants and the impact to
varying is limited however there are
some assurances so we are seeing
more mobility in the community of people
being unwell
um and testing through Hospital testing
and community service testing is um
bringing about more returns and positive
covers and clinical settings and being
able to PCR so that they can
genotyping the labs to work out which
variance it is so the new variant is
appearing for when we kind of elaborate
results
however what is reassuring is although
it appears to be making people more and
well and there are very rather have been
no death linked to the new area and it's
not being treated as a bearing of
concern which means there's um potential
for it not to be affected by the vaccine
program
so and the other area is just be mindful
that lfds do pick up this bearing I
don't see lots of questions
are there as effects because they are
and they do continue to pick up this
area and books to have a lab tests
running at the moment to make sure that
led they stay in touch with the um
variants that are coming through as well
so there's some key
um Point Theory
there was an outbreak in a care home in
East England which has been linked to
this area but just to say that everybody
who became unwell and lots of people in
home became in the world only one person
is hospital and all has seen children so
again that's quite a for sure I'm
considering what we're dealing with
told us that within the next one to two
weeks we'll know more but at the moment
the key is and you know what I'm saying
here's vaccination so please promote
vaccination across any eligible groups
that you're working with and any staff
this stuff is really crucial as well
particularly our staff working in Fair
homes and Home Care settings and so
vaccination and also what we need to do
is think about looking at George how we
get those vaccination messages out into
our communities and through our museums
to other people do come forward for
their vaccine I go through around
there is concern around Hospital
admissions that I've raises this morning
we're going to talk this through
um our electronic board systems the
other aspects local that we need to
really think about is reinforcing all
IPC measures and coverage related
guidance so I'll be speaking to our
adult social care colleagues around
making sure that all our practitioners
are really really focusing on good IPC
practices
impacts on children so we are being
advice to continue our current processes
I don't want to say that should be all
right
but at the moment we're really short
around so
um
with Kobe that we are maybe sure that
the vaccine is an absolutely crucial
learning of the system we could really
promote that information a good
accurate position at the moment so thank
you
and
and we are actually performing on tag
now so I have no other guidance and
thank you everybody for joining me today
thank you see you next time